hey yeah it seems like there's a party
going on or something
it's so I think I'm cringing the whole
thing was awkward
so the end of episode three we meet your
character right we meet Jack Alby thinks
nothing of it but then in episode four
you'd steal my girl sorry bro
it was sad as your mate as Leo to watch
you go through that thank you as Jack it
was really quite hilarious
I think he likes huh
all right see I'm pretty hot now these
jackets were a bad idea it was just
tiniest all these jackets off
good idea yeah thank you I was gonna say
the same thing
that was so smooth so how did you jump
ship so quickly from from Porsche to
Lucia we're on vacation right Anything
Goes
I think he's at that point I'll be just
looking for like the distraction yeah
your characters let's make them jealous
and then she is like let's just let's
make them jealous
don't let her win
[Music]
yeah Haley and I yeah you guys are just
like horns in our game yeah
for you why did you shoot your pants
underwear I'll put one for
specifications no so why do you think
Porsche is so attracted to Jack what do
you think draws her in and makes her
jump ship so quickly from
some would say a really great guy she's
a place in her life where she's looking
for some fun
oh
[Music]
wow she has some feelings for Alby but
he just doesn't make her feel alive the
way she needs to right now and Jack just
kind of does
I still don't understand why Abby isn't
here she is that mad and can we just not
she's going to get a divorce she can't
do that yes she can why can't she you
can't let her do that
I think Alby and his father and his
grandfather I think they all perceive
masculinity based on kind of how Society
perceived it at the time that they were
raised he almost can't understand how
it's different
Dominic he's kind of in the middle he
was raised obviously by birth so he has
that stuff ingrained in him but Alby is
also teaching him and I think this show
explores his like needle kind of going
back and forth between the two
it's for your mom oh
perfect she's gonna love them you can't
just buy people off Dad I'm happy to
talk to him she respects me no she does
not
[Music]
if I had to go on holiday with one of
the characters it would probably be my
own he's just fun if you want an
adventure huh
stick with me
I know how to have fun in the sandbox
you know what I mean
I don't know what you mean I mean I
don't want to steal your answer but Jack
I'm gonna pick Jack Jack's a fun time
we'd have fun oh babe
you know what mine I do a Negroni yeah
yeah yeah what's mine
um uh uh a pina colada sure it honestly
sounds amazing
because you don't have one do you have
one
I would have a loose schedule and a
flexible schedule yeah yeah I think I'm
with you on that you need to you need to
kind of have an idea and have an idea
and it kind of listen to your body if
you're tired this is what I love about
you you just always do you just know
what the right thing to do is
[Music]